vamos a la revista de prensa de Francia
24 aquí en directo América y para ello
saludo a mi compañera Rosa Pérez más
deudor Rosa Buen día para usted Buen día
Ángela amanecimos con la imagen de un
globo blanco en el cielo los supuestos
balones espía Qué son y por qué se
continúan usando the Guardian nos lo
explica efectivamente Ángela no porque
ha habido pues mucho interés alrededor
de que es exactamente este objeto
esférico no que el pentágono ha dicho
que ha detectado en su zona aérea en la
zona aérea estadounidense que
supuestamente sería un balón espía chino
bien en todo caso lo que se espera antes
de entrar más en detalle es que este
tipo de inteligencia se vaya usando cada
vez más en el futuro a pesar de ser
bastante antigua como vamos a ver ahora
y es que dice este artículo que con el
espacio digamos fuera de la atmósfera
terrestre no el espacio exterior tan
congestionado y disputado la zona
subespacial es decir la zona más alta de
la atmósfera se plantea como un nuevo
dominio crucial para vigilancia y el
espionaje Internacional
que son Entonces los valores espía Pues
bueno lones espías de Ángela no dejan de
ser un equipo de espionaje que puede ser
una cámara un radar etcétera suspendidos
de un globo aerostático no que flota
digamos en el cielo sin embargo no hay
límite nos explica este artículo para la
tecnología que pueda integrarse en este
globo y como comentábamos en la era de
los satélites señales de texto que es
paradigmático esté creciente interés por
los globos señala que esto se debe Por
una parte a que cada vez hay más armas
como lásers o armas cinéticas que
digamos se usan para disparar contra los
satélites o para desactivarlos por otro
lado dice aunque los globos no ofrecen
el mismo nivel de vigilancia que los
satélites son más fáciles de recuperar y
también más baratos de lanzar no se
necesita un lanzador espacial dice por
otro lado escanean más territorio desde
una altitud más baja y también pueden
pasar más tiempo porque se mueven más
sobre un área determinada esto
explicaría por qué se utilizan más usted
nos adelantaba que sin embargo es una
tecnología antigua cuando se usaron por
primera vez pues se remonta el concepto
digamos la idea a lo que sería la década
de 1860 concretamente durante la Guerra
Civil de Estados Unidos y es que la
Unión El Norte recordemos usaba no este
concepto en lugar de montar una cámara
sobre un globo si no se ponía una
persona con unos binoculares para
recoger inteligencia Y también mandar
mensajes y a bien sea a través del
código morse o con un papel atado a una
piedra posteriormente tanto china como
la unión soviética lo usaron bastante
durante la Guerra Fría y en los últimos
años enseñará este texto esta tecnología
ha cobrado pues mucho interés en Estados
Unidos si bien digamos para hacerlo
volar en un espacio aéreo extranjero se
necesita un permiso bueno y según los
analistas citados en este artículo de
declaración Por qué china habría lanzado
este globo bien concretamente se quien
es profesor de seguridad e inteligencia
internacional dice es poco probable que
los chinos no esperarán ser detectados
dado el alto nivel de vigilancia del
espacio aéreo de Estados Unidos
probablemente de hecho que los
detectarán Era uno de los objetivos con
dos resultados en mente uno avergonzar a
Estados Unidos y de paso recoger cierta
inteligencia Y dos que Estados Unidos se
diera cuenta de que china está al
corriente no está al día en esta carrera
armamentística de inteligencia espacial
y que está replicando la tecnología por
la que también está interesada en
Estados Unidos dice esta en la lista de
seguridad Alexander Neil que seguramente
el globo será un elemento más de tensión
entre China y Estados Unidos pero que
sin embargo no tendrá un gran valor la
inteligencia que haya podido recoger en
estos días lo cual hace parte de la vida
diaria en la dinámica de estos dos
países ahora vamos a cambiar de tema
porque un asunto que está llenando los
titulares es la expulsión de una
congresista del comité de asuntos
exteriores de cámara de representantes
de los Estados Unidos exactamente
hablamos de ilano Omar que ha sido como
bien decías expulsada no debido a la
mayoría republicana en la cámara de
representantes y bien hemos querido
recoger aparte de los titulares
internacionales que señalan esta
expulsión un artículo de opinión firmado
por peter weynard articulista y analista
político en el New York Times que antes
de que tuviera lugar esta votación ya
señaló cuando ilanomar hace preguntas
sus colegas deberían escuchar y como
decíamos no publicado tres días antes de
esta expulsión decía se da sería un gran
error expulsar del comité de asuntos
exteriores a la única persona que
describe constantemente la política
exterior estadounidense tal y como la
experimenta gran parte del mundo no dice
que ilanomar es la única que hace
preguntas incómodas y que realmente no
cree en este mito bipartidista de que
Estados Unidos se mueve a nivel
internacional por un interés por
exportar la democracia no y los valores
de la libertad sino pues por otros
intereses y que ella empatiza y hace de
traductora con las personas que ven la
política internacional estadounidense en
forma de negocio armamentístico de
sanciones o de drones sobrevolando sus
casas Bueno vamos al cierre muy
rápidamente con la cifra del Éxodo de
periodistas de Rusia por el músculo
Times exactamente que para cerrar
rápidamente señala un reporte del net
freedoms project que dice al menos 1000
periodistas habrían abandonado Rusia
desde que Rusia invadió Ucrania hace
prácticamente un año pues Rosa Le
agradezco mucho y pues estaremos
esperando Cuál es su próxima revista de
prensa Muchas gracias Ángel hasta la
semana que viene